fauci was asked this weekend about
what's going on in China because you
know China has this zero coveted policy
which has led to if you think Michigan
and New York and California had crazy
lockdowns I mean they are locking people
in buildings they are closing cities it
is absolutely insane fauci was asked
about China's approach what is going on
in China and why do they seem to be in a
worse place than anyone else in the
world well their approach has been very
very severe and rather Draconian in the
kinds of shutdowns without a seeming
purpose I mean if you're having a
situation if you could recall you know
almost three years ago when we were
having our hospitals overrun you
remember the situation in New York City
you had to do something immediately to
shut down that flow so remember we were
talking about flattening the curve and
the social distancing and restrictions
and shutdown which was never really
complete is done for a temporary period
of time for the purpose of regrouping
getting more personal protective
equipment getting people vaccinated it
seems that in China it was just a very
very strict extraordinary lockdown where
you lock people in the house but without
any seemingly end game to it if the end
game was to let's get everybody
vaccinated including and particularly
the vulnerable then you could see how a
temporary lockdown like that but they
went into a prolonged lockdown without
any seeming purpose or end game to it
which is really doesn't make Public
Health sense ah Draconian without a
purpose now could it be without a
purpose would a Communist Regime that is
bent on maintaining power and bent on
keeping people all doing the exact same
thing and not questioning Authority and
all that could there be a purpose behind
them locking their people down could
there be a purpose there he can't figure
it out it doesn't make any sense why
would that communist regime do that he
has no freaking idea